welcome to a very special Collider
heroes interview with living legend jim
Starlin thank you so much for being here
my pleasure now this movie is the
culmination of 22 movies but this exact
saga has been surrounding a character
you invented what was it like way back
in the day when Marvel first told you
they were gonna make fan oohs did you
think he'd translate Marvel never told
me they were going to make that first I
I wasn't working for Marvel at the time
when the first Avengers movie came out
and I only heard about it on the
Internet
two days before and it was kind of
interesting because I went to a midnight
showing because I said this can't be
right so we got to the theater and never
ceased to fellows behind us who sort of
talked throughout the movie not not
offensively so but I could hear him and
I could make out that one was comic book
fan and the other was a cartoon fan and
so in the final credits ran and Thanos
appears I hear the comic book fan going
Thanos and then I hear the car cartoon
fan go who stand up and I realized at
that point that the next few years are
going to get kind of surreal and they've
certainly have that's a beautiful moment
you got the internet right behind you
yes exactly five seconds times with your
you your incredible work which continues
on in comics at Marvel and in your
independence but you and put your stamp
on and co-create a lot of the stuff that
they have been throwing up on the screen
for the last several years especially
with your work in the cosmic area
redefining Marvel creating Thanos I like
have there and just curious can you
speak to sort of watching Marvel the MCU
go into space in that area and the way
it has your step all over it well with
the advent of the computers in movies
everything changed
when I first started in comics in the
70s we could blow to movies away on what
we put in the comics because I could
draw
our motto spaceships and you couldn't
see the wires hanging now with the
computers I can work for a year on a
drawing and never get anywhere nearest
complexes one frame in this in-game
movie so it's been kind of interesting
watching it build them heading off for
the more cosmic stuff as sort of a
natural progression because that's the
way the comic books worked up through
the 70s it was very earth-based
because that's what everyone was
comfortable with and then in the
seventies we had it a bunch of young
guys coming in to replace all the guys
from the 1940s who were retiring and we
started going off into different
directions and it's reflected in the
movies because all the young kids who
are reading our comics in the 70s are
now so it's a little strange sometimes
now Pharaoh's beautifully mirrors the
comic in an infinity war by even like no
the way he's dressed and at the end him
going to the farm and I'm gonna try to
lead more infinity war for now but that
choice to have him literally have your
ending reflected and there was a
different journey to get to the ending
but for me it was really the ending I
thought we'd get to but in a direction I
never thought would come what was it
like for you watching infinity war for
the first time seeing a character that
you had so many thoughts about take
different choices but then still at the
end have effectively the Scarecrow and
the armour well I had worked with movie
companies on scripts for adaptations and
novels who had worked on before never
got made into movies but so I knew what
to expect that only a fool should expect
his piece of work or her piece of work
to be adapted like Carbon Copy into a
movie not they're spending billions of
dollars you know they're gonna make some
changes so I came in there with the I
think it was pretty good attitude is
it's going to be what it is and let's
see where they go
I was quite surprised on how
in spirit if not exactly to let her
Markus and McFeely and the Russos
brothers went with this and so I was
very pleasantly surprised and I've
enjoyed what they've done with it like I
said he's he's a little bit different
it's a little bit different but it's a
little bit same the first movie I was
sitting there going there seen my scene
so it all worked out pretty nicely
yeah I've enjoyed the ride so far I
would like to know if there's any
character that you've invented to date
that you feel like what translates the
movies now that we are at this advanced
point and CGI is there anyone you want
to see that you you've been so many
amazing characters catching up to your
imagination I had a deal set up for a TV
series of Dredd startling yes and
unfortunately the producer died and so
that kind of killed the project so we're
trying to get it brought back to life
now and so I have high hopes for that
inside the Marvel Universe I'd like to
see pit patrol show up oh yes and I
think there's a good chance because it
looks like warlocks gonna come in there
yeah and eventually you know he's gonna
need a sidekick oh and pip the troll
would be perfect for it yes I love that
I'd like to know with endgame we're
gonna do endgame now cuz I'm drunk I'm
so contained with emotion about endgame
the moment you pop up which is one of my
favorite moments in the movie of amazing
moments in the movie because to me
that's the biggest we know the source
material of what we've made here look
it's jim Starlin what was the process
like of getting that happen did they
call did they get an email like how does
that happen I heard that the film was
being made in infinity war and on my
Facebook page I just kiddin lead took a
phrase from I think it's Bugs Bunny you
know and said mr. and mr. Russo I'm
ready for my close-up and somehow or
another that got to them amazing
about a week later I got a call from a
producer at Marvel and asking though I
could come down and to Atlanta and do
this and I went let me check my schedule
yes yes yes so we got down there and
that was a terrific trip all into itself
because apparently everybody there had
not been able to talk to anybody about
this for a year and a half because
they're all non-disclosure agreement I
know yeah and I came down there and did
the same thing signed on the dotted line
and I came there expecting you know
we're gonna do the scene and nothing
about shows off and that'll be the end
of it and we'll be sitting in the hotel
room instead as soon as we got there
Markus and McFeely back true we want to
talk to you you know they were very open
about everything that they were doing I
was I was so blown away by that part of
it alone that I didn't listen to
anything other than what they were
talking about with Thanos and so you
know all the Avengers stuff we'll need
in one ear and out the other and so I
still had a really good surprise when I
went to the movie and yeah a lot of this
stuff I just haven't seen infinity war
was very tried and sure to the comics
and endgame definitely derails more into
MCU territory because they're solving
problems that have been set up for ten
years instead of following a comic and
they also didn't have half the
characters we had a comic book a
different story
it wasn't it wasn't a different
experience for you watching infinity war
which is such a love letter to your work
versus watching endgame which is truly
just a ride like a roller coaster of
this is all different yeah I mean the
writers said that they were you know
bouncing off a lot of my time-travel
stories and that thing so you know I
felt kind of good about that but it is a
hold if it is a divergence from a
gauntlet it's it's this epic story with
all these emotional roller coasters
flying around in it that like I said I
was
I knew a bit about it but he didn't know
the whole story and I was you know
stunned I didn't buy the first demise of
somebody particular but you know a
half-hour in there and I've seen him
another scenes in the trailer so I know
but yeah it was it was just this you
know the hard part about going to these
premieres is you have to run into the
writers and directors afterwards and in
my case I was so stunned that I'm almost
completely inarticulate I'm sitting
there going I was a terrific movie there
so later I'm articulate nothing I was
able to communicate with them on that
but it's just when you walk out of the
theater also I wanted it was a drink you
know I'm safe Wow and you see this at
least three four more times before I got
it all in my head
ya know it's an incredible ride are
there any standouts for you in terms of
sort of surprising adaptations like one
thing you did like their version of
nebula for instance is very different
from one we've seen but that feels sort
of true to the intensity of that
characters experience are there any sort
of stand out like background characters
or things that you've enjoyed watching
transformed in that way yes well maybe I
was kind of an interesting story because
another writer created you or her rather
and claimed that she was Stannis's
daughter biological daughter
I took exception to that because I
figure anyone who worships death is not
going to procreate all that readily make
sense so when I did the Infinity
Gauntlet I disavowed everybody or the
notion that she was actually as his
daughter and took it a little bit far
and started didn't treat her all that
well in the story moments as a result of
that dove read but yes but she was not
treated in the best way by me and the
directors and writers decided to go a
little less easy route and I think they
did a really interesting job I love that
scene where she's hanging there half
disassembled and Thanos walks in with
Gamora and he's so cold and remote and
spooky in that scene and you know the
other thing that I really liked that
they did that wasn't in the book was
when he gets a couple of stones he takes
off the armor yeah it just didn't occur
to me today he doesn't need it anymore
of course of the comics we want to see
that image but you know I went and I
know a lot of folks got upset by that
but I went yeah makes sense why didn't I
think of that I love that I love that
with your work you have a love of it but
you see the adaptation is a separate
thing and a lot of times I think it's
really hard for it's your baby but to
see it transiting through someone else
and I love that the medium of comic
books allows for translation like this
movie is very different from the comics
but then it brings people back to the
comics like people go back and read
infinity saga as a different animal have
you had any interactions with fans that
were like oh you saw something in this
than I didn't see because they're coming
out from a new way not so much anything
like that but I mean I have gotten a lot
of new fans from the port of books
because everything's been reprinted yeah
since these things came out you know I
had no trouble with the adaptation I act
as I was going along I kept wondering
what would Arthur Conan Doyle think if
he saw all the different versions of
Sherlock Holmes over the past century I
mean would he even
but no I figure there's the comic book
there's that what is that I did there
and after that there are adaptations
that you know other people are going to
come along and do other than of stories
in the comics yeah you know when you do
something on a work-for-hire basis you
have to say goodbye to it eventually and
move on and you I'm sure it's have
become aware that I believe as of the
end of last year when Diamond comics
released their charts for last year
Infinity Gauntlet was the best-selling
graphic novel of 2018 I didn't know that
I always broke some kind of record
on the collection thing but you know it
was number one that's kind of it's just
that it's the the diamond number so the
book star mark and all that stuff but
but it was it was amazing for us to see
like yeah that was you you made a lot of
new fans and I think yep back in such a
big way like I and I love the movies
reach such a different audience that
we're actually creating new comic fans
instead of just losing them to time now
with the comic itself it is so full of
vibrant colors and it's so full of this
energy in this pace when you were
developing it with such a great team
like George Perez and Ron and then the
Rubenstein was that collaborative
process like you guys sitting in a room
and going like this insane color and
this insane frame like how did the
actual writing of infinity saga go did
you guys piece it out or I mostly did it
with editor Craig Anderson okay Ron who
was writing or drawing the Silver Surfer
lived out in California I was in New
York at the time so he wasn't actually
into the process of that and George got
pulled in unexpectedly we we thought Ron
was going to draw the Infinity Gauntlet
right from the beginning it Marvel zoned
at that point by a guy named Ron Perlman
and it was a time when they wanted to
squeeze every last sense they could out
of the readership every Mar every x-men
had a his own title at one point and so
I came onto the sofa surfer and it
started selling pretty well and so they
said well we got to do something else
let's do some special project and that's
where the Thanos Quest came in and
early things early sales for the Thanos
quests were really good so they said we
need something more because I was having
I was going to go back and finish off
the story in the server surfer and so
they said let's do some real big event
and I said well get me a bunch of
characters that I could work with and a
few of the editors were pretty cool
about that and said oh yeah you used to
Hulk you into this but the x-men editor
said I can't use any of them and so the
editor and she finally said you got to
give them at least two x-men for this so
that's why we got Cyclops and Wolverine
over some of the books did tie-ins to it
and so when gauntlet came out and
started selling all the other books who
had tie-ins they they went up in sales
also so a year later we did the infinity
war and at that point everybody wanted
their characters in this book including
some that hadn't even come out yet
I remember getting Xeroxes of this guy
named sleepwalker he's got to be in the
book he's our new character and the best
I could do is have him walking by in the
background no idea what director and
everyone was like we've got these people
we need you to use and put that script
sleepwalker walks by in the background
shrug at least we gave them something
that I will say just for our audience
you can get that famous quest material
is collected in a new edition in Silver
Surfer it's fantastic if you have not
read the original fantasy quest
two-parter I feel like that was
something that sort of like didn't get
enough credit for a long time and it's
very nice to see people sort of going
back and appreciating my way I really
like panic quest has always been my
favorite Thanos story because he's never
been as nasty and as rotten as he is in
that particular book have you read any
of the new Thanos stuff now that he's
come back to the mainstream now that
he's back to popularity in the comics
themselves no I'm finishing off
editing sort of had an agreement up in
Marvel that there was going to be the
cinematic Thanos Marvel Comics Santos
and then my Thanos over a graphic novels
what you've been doing in a series of
stand-alones that you should all be
check around and Alan Davis is finishing
off the last one right now it looks
terrific but I lost my point here oh
yeah yes so basically you know what I
did was go off and do this own thing and
I still lost the traffic yes question
just whether or not I've been keeping
track of the news yes no so I have
because of all that nonsense I just went
through I did reading the other books
for right now until after I get done
with the editing in the next week or so
and which case and I want to read Donny
Gates's and yeah to begin with and that
Donny Cates is I was really impressed
with the fact that it felt like the
spirit of Thanos but I also was
surprised and it's nice to have like a
parent is very versatile the character
you can have a writer really shape them
and yeah I was really impressed yeah and
I get along really well with him we've
met in number of conventions and I've
told him as soon as I'm done it's a
collection now I don't have to do all
those pamphlets now I have one last
question for me so if you have a last
question you should go first cuz I got I
got a nowhere Thanos's helicopter came
from I've know for years it's been
haunting me I've really it's the most
visual thing I have well when you were
kind of work for hire character other
people are going to come along and work
on it and Marvel had this book that was
supposed to be for really young readers
the intr yeah into the market net and
Larry Lieber Stan's brother he was
writing it and he just grabbed up Thanos
and had him robbing banks and had his
Thanos copter and
you know they showed it to me after it
came out and I went you know I'm not
gonna reference this in fact I'm gonna
return this yeah and now it's one of the
most popular memes out there every time
anything with a nose quest comes up on
my Google Alerts you know half the time
there's a modern comics era we now live
in a world where like we're keeping
around digital copies of things where it
has become it has become customary to
reprint trade paperbacks you helped
pioneer the idea of a story that should
be go gone back to and enjoy it with
death of Captain Marvel being one of the
first graphic novels as we think of them
when you in the the original 70s cosmic
stuff did you hope that that would all
be collected and remembered and that
we'd still be able to have it on
bookshelves today or was it just I know
the comics environment has changed so
much over time were you accepting that
the issues might go out there into the
world and that might be it our only
concern back in the 70s was get it out
on time I remember story conferences
with Roy Thomas and he was the only
editor up there at the time and now this
issue of Captain Marvel I'm gonna use
the super-skrull go go and so you know
no no I had no idea that this was going
to grow into what it was I mean the
movies were never on the horizon because
of the you know they didn't have two
computers to do anything good like this
now
and I always kind of expect the Thanos
is going to be too strange and esoteric
to become ever a part of anything
mainstream I'm you know I have Josh
Whedon and Kevin Feige to thank for that
I mean why they decided to settle on him
and still got me but III appreciate them
having done so I love Josh Brolin's
portrayal like teaming up with everyone
and I think he's the most photorealistic
character I think
if a nose is just I love that his hair
grow slightly and like you can see that
as the movie evolved Zand was there
anything with Thanos I have a real last
question apologies
was there anything with Thanos that
surprised you visually mentioned the
armor and stuff but was he as you
imagine translated a movie once you
accepted that he was going to be
translated well I always figured he was
going to be computer animated I didn't
know that they were gonna do this motion
capture yeah and so Josh Brolin was
never on my radar at all enduring my
dream casting you know that I didn't my
studio all by myself I was thinking more
like a voice like post-cancer as Arnold
Schwarzenegger or an interest Elba
somebody's got that gravelly voice like
he hadn't Luther yeah
and so when Josh Brolin came in I went
cheese you know never thought about him
but after seeing him in this role I
can't imagine anybody else playing him
now he is his study of the character and
just how he had him moving because it's
all Josh up there on the screen and it
doesn't look like many more but it is
him doing everything that is there and
you know he's just the cadence of the
voice the movement that just the weight
that he gave to the character I just
found that astounding yeah I said that's
my guy yeah well folks if you haven't
seen endgame yet please check out Thanos
in all of his glory infinity war and
endgame really made this character shine
thank you so much for all of your
amazing work thank you for being here my
pleasure
I've loved your work from childhood to
now and I can't wait to see more of it
including pip Patrol let's make it
happen society thanks again so much
thank you guys hey
you